You're all ready to make
the sandwich of your dreams.
Turkey, tomato, and Swiss
on a bed of romaine lettuce
sandwiched between two
slices of sourdough.
Classic, but oh no!
What's this? Mold? Ugh.
But look, good news, the mold's
only on part of the bread
so I could just cut that
away and be fine, right?
There's no such thing as a
clean part of moldy bread.
That's because mold is
a fungus like mushrooms.
The caps on the surface
are easy enough to spot,
but there's a vast network
of subterranean roots
called hyphae that you can't see.
So let's take another look
at that bread of yours.
Ugh, disgusting.
Well, maybe you can
just grab another piece
from the same loaf.
Well, that's not such a good idea, either.
because by the time the
mold sprouts its fuzzy head,
what you're really seeing
is the reproductive part
of the mold called sporangiums.
Each sporangium releases
tens of thousands of spores,
so even though you can't
see it, that entire loaf
could be teeming with fungus.
But it seems like such a
waste to just throw it out.
After all, you eat mold
on purpose all the time
like the mold that goes into
making cheese, soy sauce,
and even life-saving
antibiotics like penicillin.
Eating a little bit on your
bread can't be that bad, right?
Well, ultimately, it's a gamble.
Just like eating a wild mushroom
many are fine, but some can be deadly.
Mold is the same way.
There are thousands of
different species of mold
many of which are harmless to humans.
But since so many types
can sprout up on food,
it's nearly impossible to know if what
you're eating is safe.
Cladosporium, for example, can
sometimes trigger allergies
but is generally harmless,
whereas other molds like
Penicillium crustosum
produce harmful poisons called Mycotoxins.
An elderly couple in 2005,
for example, was admitted
to the hospital after eating a can of soup
contaminated with this kind of mold.
They had severe muscle tremors
but eventually recovered.
But other molds, like
Rhizopus stolonifer, can have
permanent effects, and you
might recognize this mold
since it commonly grows on bread.
Blue green with black
splotches and super fuzzy.
In rare cases, it can
prompt a deadly infection
called Zygomycosis, which
causes your blood to clot
and can ultimately starve
your cells of oxygen
to the point that they die.
And it's not like bacteria,
where a little heat
will eliminate the threat,
because high temperatures won't
break down the Mycotoxins.
And since you have no clue
which one you're about
to put in your mouth, ask yourself
is it really worth the risk?